it was an evening in paris to forget but
one many liverpool fans will no doubt
remember
because of these scenes outside the stud
de france just hours before kickoff
the question many are trying to answer
is who caused this chaos in the capital
uefa claim liverpool fans arrived late
and the french today adamant their
forces of law and order acted
proportionately blaming thousands of
british fans with fake tickets and the
culture of causing trouble
at nine pm only fifty percent of the
british supporters had got into their
section which does show the difficulty
that arose and only arose from the
entrance relating to the liverpool
supporters and not the other entrances
there was massive fraud an industrial
level and organization of fake tickets
ten minutes into the match we said we
weren't going to get in and we did leave
because we felt unsafe but for james
there's no consolation instead of being
inside the stadium he was tear gassed
twice and forced to watch from a hotel
bar we were going like this with our
tickets to say like we've got legitimate
tickets no one was scanning them for us
and then that's when i said the barriers
were getting thrown by the locals tea
gas was getting thrown bottles were
getting thrown
and i said my uncle he's 68 years of age
he's not well he was at hillsborough and
he said it was just been going back like
he said he was going to be like another
hillsborough the way it was being run
the organization was
terrible
the events of saturday night have turned
into what can only be described as a
blame game liverpool football club are
now urging uefa to carry out a full and
formal investigation called echoed by
the british government and this man too
the mayor of liverpool's city region
targeted by thieves in paris it's only
important if it's independent i'll tell
you now
if differential authorities do it what
the conclusions will be if we don't
respond to what happened and learn the
lessons from this
next time
people might not be so lucky
france has dismissed claims that there
are any doubts about their suitability
to host next year's rugby world cup and
the 2024 olympics but this was center
stage for the biggest night in european
football a night that went so wrong for
so many intimate rasheed sky news
liverpool